Janet how many Janet's have there been
there have been 25 generations of Janet
each new update of Janet gains more
wisdom and social abilities fun fact the
first Janet had a click wheel so it's
like aging for a human you're growing up
that's how I like to think of a TV I
can't eat so every time there's a new
version of Janet I like to take a piece
of birthday cake and smash it around
where my mouth is janet has learned and
groans she's essentially living a life
we can't kill her not with that attitude
we can't listen man I'm dead you're dead
we all died and now we're killing her
take a forward not what that means at
all Eleanor here we are just press that
button in it goodbye
Janet aah Chiti I can see that you're
worried and I just want to assure you I
am NOT human
and I cannot feel pain oh thank you that
helps however I should warn you I am
programmed with a fail-safe measure as
you approach the kill switch I will
begin to beg for my life it's just there
in case of an accidental shutdown but it
will seem very real cool so who's doing
this me or you
all right I think I have to being a
bystander seems worse somehow okay here
we go
no no no please please please don't hurt
me I don't wanna die please again I am
NOT human I can't die
I am simply an anthropomorphize vessel
of knowledge built to make your life
easier you're pleading seems so real oh
yes it is a very effective failsafe ah
you want a robot killed right you have
to do it yourself
Eleanor Eleanor no no no please wait
wait wait Eleanor I have kids I have
three beautiful children
Tyler Emma and little tiny baby Philip
look at Tyler Tyler has asthma but he is
battling it like a champ look at him no
Eleanor look at them so realistic
Eleanor again I'm not human this is a
stock photo of the crowd at the
Nickelodeon Kids Choice Awards that's
right it's not real let's do this right
please I have so much to live for no
we're not even here hey guys what's
going on
now party was lame so I bailed then I
saw you so I followed you here oh look a
button
[Music]
oh man I wanted to push that button
no cool dude whoa what happened to Jenny
she's dead guy I killed her not killed
remember Janet was not a living being so
she can't be killed attention I have
been murdered attention I have been
murdered attention I have been murdered
attention what do we do Illinois what do
we do Chiti you just murdered Janet we
have to flee your crime scene
[Music]
you